haha we did it you guys after suffering
through three horrendous Kreme wolves
Star Wars is great again
the force awakens gave us awesome new
characters and now we get spin-off
movies in between new episodes like
rogue one which has cool new characters
in a set before Episode four wait that
means there's more prequels
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show where we get to celebrate our
favorite franchises by bending over
backwards to justify their horrible plot
holes and leaps of logic where are
midi-chlorians
midi-chlorians are a microscopic
life-form nope no not today those wounds
have yet to heal so hey it's nearly
December and that means we're only weeks
away from the biggest celebration of the
year oh not Christmas Hanukkah Ramadan
or the Fiesta of Our Lady Guadalupe is
the release of rogue one a Star Wars
story yes sir a legitimate excuse to
take a break from your family bickering
about eggnog and stockings to go watch
spaceships explode and people choke each
other to death with their minds it's
beginning to look a lot like Christmas
ha I love the holidays now I'll admit it
I was a bit worried with them restarting
the Star Wars franchise with the force
awakens last year but hey my fears were
put aside because the force awakens
turned out pretty good but you know if
there's something that cranks my
skepticism levels up to 11 it's a
spin-off series being slotted in between
main series releases so I'm hoping
against hope that we can keep the
positive streak going this year with
Star Wars spin-off rogue one in case
you've been frozen in carbonite and
haven't seen the trailers rogue one is
the story of a ragtag group of rebel
fighters who endeavor to steal the Death
Star plans shortly before the events of
the og Star Wars a new hope admittedly
it's a really cool idea but it also got
me thinking how are they gonna explain
away the fact that we haven't
encountered any of the major characters
from rogue one in episodes 4 or 5 6 or 7
the episodes that are supposedly coming
after them in the timeline I suppose the
easiest way to do it would be to kill
everyone but is that really likely no
kid is gonna buy the action figure of a
resistance pilot who gets killed after
15 minutes of screen time and George
Lucas needs his merch money damn it and
think about it why would the trailers
have built up jyn erso Felicity Jones's
character so much if she and the rogue
one movie weren't gonna connect to this
new trilogy that's
released so it almost seems like Disney
has written themselves into a corner we
have a team of characters led by jyn
erso that seems like it should have
significance outside of rogue one and
tie-in to the main series movies but
those characters can't be instrumental
to the rebel cause
since they surely would have shown up or
at least been mentioned sometime in
episodes 4 5 & 6
IRA Bell I know considering they would
have you know completed one of the most
important missions against the empire
ever stealing the plans for the Death
Star and so when you have writers
painted into a corner my friends you
call a theorist because even though
we've only got a few trailers to analyze
and much of the extended universe is
questionably cannon at this point I've
got a way to bridge that gap one that
explains away everything and predicts
the plotline not only for this
December's movie but next year's episode
8 as well I'm a hundred percent
confident in saying that jyn erso is
coming back in Episode eight but
probably not in the way that you think
yeah yeah yeah matpat we know where
you're going with this you're gonna say
that jyn erso is Ray's mom that theories
been around for months thank you so much
for your skeptical comment hypothetical
Internet viewer and you know what I
can't really fault you entirely for
thinking that because honestly that's
where this theory began probably the
biggest question we're left with at the
end of the force awakens is who ray
really is and where she comes from I
mean you look at how jyn erso is
described in the road one trailers it's
hard not to make the comparison badass
young women left on their own on a
desert planet as teenagers who happen to
sport brown hair and a British accent
it's compelling on the surface but then
you look a bit deeper and that's pretty
much all the evidence that you got there
are some fairly sizeable issues that
don't work out this scenario like for
instance the timeline jyn erso is played
by felicity jones who's currently 33
years old maybe Gina's a little bit
younger than that in the movies but she
isn't gonna be a young teenager like ray
or Luke during the main thrust of her
action in wrote one so considering that
rogue one takes place before the events
of a new hope that would make jyn erso
at least 10 years older than Luke
Skywalker who himself is looking pretty
ragged at the end of the force awakens
so are we supposed to believe that
someone well older than old Luke has a
teenage daughter it's a bit of a stretch
Andrew
accents it's not like jyn erso is the
only brunette that we've ever seen in
this universe who speaks with a British
accent Mon Mothma Queen Amidala heck
even Carrie Fisher couldn't decide
whether she was British or not in
Episode four more you tighten your grip
tuck more star systems we'll skip to me
laughing gasps somebody get this big
walking carpet out of my way and lastly
if gin was indeed Ray's mom it wouldn't
do so much to explain Ray's force powers
as the director of rogue one Gareth
Edwards explains about the movie quote
it comes down to a group of individuals
that don't have magic powers that have
to bring hope to the galaxy it's about
the fact that God's not coming to save
us and we're on our own the absence of
the Jedi is omnipresent in the film it
hangs over the whole movie end quotes
and if you're still clinging to the idea
that Ray could be Jin's daughter with
some Jedi father let's let Daisy Ridley
Ray herself
- those dreams right out the door for
you in an interview at the MTV Movie
Awards she said both that she knew who
Ray's parents are and also this I'm not
being funny you guys but just because
she's white and got brown hair
it doesn't mean she's my mom I also
don't know if that will work out
timewise she's obviously not gonna say
anything with absolute certainty one way
or the other because PR is a tricky
mistress and Disney doesn't want its
secrets getting out of its vault but it
doesn't look good for the Gina's Ray's
mom theory and you know what I'm
perfectly fine with that because there's
a much better theory that unifies the
rogue one squadron into the main Star
Wars narrative by connecting them with
another group one that we know almost
nothing about but that we know is gonna
play a huge role in the upcoming Star
Wars main movies and that is the Knights
of Ren remember those guys maybe not by
name but you definitely remember seeing
them as they're the black clad Warriors
led by kylo Ren the ones we caught a
brief glimpse of and that weirdo vision
that Rey has when she finds Luke's
lightsaber in the force awakens
mysterious dream sequences you say you
know when things like that pop up I'm
all over that like sand getting all up
in Anakin's business I don't like sand
it's coarse rough and here
and it gets everyone that dream sequence
has stuck with me since I first saw
force awakens and now I finally have the
theory of how it all fits together what
I'm proposing today is that this group
in rogue one turns into this group from
the sequel trilogy prepare to be
convinced let's start off with the
original teaser for rogue one Forest
Whitaker's character Saul Guerrero has a
little speech about jyn erso that feels
awfully for shadowy let's take a close
look at that what will you do when they
catch you you do it they break you if
you continue to fight what will you
become first off he says when they catch
you rather than if they catch you and
that's exactly the kind of negative
thinking that a rebellion doesn't need
saw yeah with that attitude they're
gonna catch you anyway those three
sentences we just heard our entire
character are a character being caught
by the enemy that character then being
broken by them and that character
eventually having a transformation and
keep in mind these teasers and trailers
are produced with tremendous care
costing hundreds of thousands to
millions of dollars where every word is
poured over by every single person
working on the brand in that company so
make no mistake it's not an accident
that just as Saul Guerrero finishes
saying what will you become that we get
a glimpse of jyn erso wearing a very
prominent imperial patch on her arm it's
most likely that that's just her
disguise to get into the Death Star and
steal the information the Rebel Alliance
needs in that moment in the movie what
that shot is hinting at is gin being
captured tortured and converted to the
dark side and honestly would that be
such a huge transformation we know gin
isn't the biggest fan of playing by the
rules anyway based on a rap sheet
forgery of Imperial documents possession
of stolen
aggravated assault resisting arrest and
honestly it would be a huge stretch for
some of the other members of rogue one
to transition to the dark side either
Bay's Malthus is a freelance assassin
who probably doesn't have an allegiance
to anyone
bori rook used to be a cargo pilot for
the Empire even the droid k2s Oh is a
reprogrammed Imperial enforcer droid I'm
not saying that they all turned heel and
gave the rebellion a big ol Stone Cold
Steve Austin middle finger isn't it
possible that rogue one was able to
steal the plans and somehow get captured
on the Death Star we know from the
trailers that Darth Vader is there and
we also know based on past movies how he
feels about not killing intruders in
fact let's take a moment to explore the
opening of episode 4 a scene that many
of us have seen dozens of times and yet
it's incredible how many plot details
we've all been so eager to overlook by
actually listening to what Darth Vader
says we get a clearer picture of what's
going on here so we know prior to the
start of the scene that Princess Leia
receives plans to the Death Star plans
that she puts on r2d2 for safekeeping
before getting herself captured but
where did those plans come from well
Vader tells us the plans for the Death
Star weren't physically captured but
instead simply transmitted to the
princess on board this ship several
transmissions have beamed the ship by
rebel spies but then why is Vader going
after this transmission shouldn't he be
going after the rebel spies who
infiltrated and transmitted them in the
first place aka the rogue one team well
it's likely he's going after the
transmissions because he and the rest of
the imperial crew have already taken
care of the people who sent them not by
killing them but capturing them
torturing them like they do Han in
Episode five and kylo repeat in Episode
seven all with the intent of making the
rogue ones
work for them hmm you might be thinking
as you smoke your little Ewok pipe and
Stroke your adorably furry chin kylo Ren
is described as the master of the
Knights of Ren but based on your theory
he would have been way too young to be a
member of that group when it was formed
if he was even worn yet at all and if
that's your concern I have just one
thing to say to you don't listen to me
listen to Adam driver the actor who
plays kylo Ren who actually addressed
this issue in an interview before saying
that the Knights of Ren quote was a
group that existed before him that he
became a part of so that if kylo Ren is
the young whippersnapper of the group
wise he described as its master well
remember that none of our rogue one
friends are force users daring pilots
sure tough fighters absolutely but when
the new guy on the team shows that he
can stop a laser in midair with his mind
powers you just go ahead and step aside
make that guy your captain
alright so Real Talk this is all well
and good but it's also well and
speculative yeah sure the members of
rogue one certainly could get captured
and become evil but for all we know they
could end up as horrible CGI slaves in
Jabba's palace like these guys
unfortunately with the Knights of Ren
having virtually no screen time yet and
the plot of road 1 largely uncertain we
have little concrete evidence to go off
of that being said the little that we do
have produces one clue that I believe
clinches this whole theory the art of
star wars the force awakens is a book
filled with sketches and concept art
that came out last year alongside
episode 7 and it's a really cool look at
the whole design process for the force
awakens that any big star Wars fan
should really check out hashtag not
sponsored but one detail in particular
caught my attention the book contains a
noteworthy sketch of the five nights of
friend here it is do they look familiar
they should the heavy looks like he
matches up well with BAE's mal miss an
assassin known for using giant weapon
phases like the heavy the most
thoroughly armored of the group and
notice the shoulder
rival he and the heavy we're the same
shoulder protection of the same shoulder
as we see from the road one trailers
this is the shoulder BAE's rests his
laser cannon on to shoot down 80 ATS
that little clip indicates that BAE's
Melba's is probably in charge of heavy
artillery which may be where the Knights
of Ren the heavy gets his name next we
have the armory which looks a whole lot
like Bodie rook
compared the dressings that they have on
their chest both of them are covered in
a vest with little compartments and
pouches Riz Ahmed his actor like it's
Bodie - a truck driver so he's
definitely the mechanic of the group one
with a full tool belt is ready for any
situation that's what it looks like the
armory is to the Knights of Ren the
utility guy the guy ready with a variety
of weapons and tools that his team might
need
then there's the sniper which matches up
with this guy cassia and compared the
rifles these two are holding with their
respective pictures the guns look pretty
similar as is the way the two characters
are holding them beyond this a lot of
promotional material for rogue one shows
casseon with a rifle of some kind so
it's quite possible that he's the
marksman of the group by the actors own
admission there's not a whole lot to
talk about this guy right now so let's
move on the next one is really easy the
monk clearly matches up with this one to
rout in way route is described as a
spiritual warrior and is shown as a calm
blind man in a robe carrying a staff if
that doesn't say bunk I'm not sure
what's gonna and if you think that your
route in way appears to be the kind of
monk who wouldn't take up arms against
anyone well know which leaves us with
one final person to account for jyn erso
the rebel the person rogue one is most
likely named for given that Bodie comes
up with the callsign while staring gin
straight in the eye we don't get a whole
lot of clues from the picture of the
last night of Ren though I suppose
they're standing in similar ways in the
two pictures that's a bit of a stretch
admittedly but you know what's not a
stretch the final knight's name which
just so happens to be the
rogue something tells me that's no
accidents
so in Jin and the team get captured at
the end of rogue one and then get
revealed as the Knights of Ren in
Episode eight just remember you heard it
here first
but until then that's just a theory a
film theory and cut I swear if jyn erso
is raised mom then they are just
deliberately screwing with our heads
because it legitimately would make no
sense just saying just saying you know
it does make sense though subscribing to
the film theorists for more mind-blowing
theories on all your favorite franchises
by clicking right here tell you what I
think I earned your subscription after
this one predicting the next two Star
Wars movies doesn't get much bigger than
that and hey if you're a fan of Star
Wars and you're gonna want to see this
it's a video calculating the impacts of
destroying the Death Star sure movie
it's all like will we beat the Empire
but the actual economic ramifications
for all these planets is devastating to
make sure you click there to check that
one out so now if you'll excuse me I
need to go put the finishing touches on
next week's theory which if you truly
are a fan of Star Wars I think you're
really gonna like
[Music]